well let's just bring you some uh news
breaking in the last few minutes it's
the uk health security agency which has
just released a briefing about its work
on the omigron variant it seems that
more than half of the people in the uk
with the variant have been double jabbed
our science correspondent thomas moore
has been looking at the data
they've looked at the the 22 cases that
were known up to the end of november and
they found 12 had been fully vaccinated
had at least two doses
two cases had had
at least one dose
and six uh hadn't been vaccinated two
there was no vaccination uh status now
it's not it's at face value that will
look quite alarming that there are so
many people who have been fully
vaccinated who are developing the
omicron variant but remember too that
the vast majority of the uk population
is now vaccinated most delta cases are
also in the fully vaccinated that in
itself shouldn't be a concern
but i think we're going to have to wait
a few more days perhaps even weeks
before we've got a full idea on how well
the vaccines are protecting against this
new variant they also
look at their surveillance for this
variant they say there's no trace yet uh
no significant trace of the of the
variant in waste water they do sampling
of the sewage systems just to look for
uh dna or journey material from the from
the viruses uh there
but that was only up until the november
the 21st and they're doing some more
analysis they also do pcr tests looking
for what's called an s gene dropout
that's indicative of omicron and various
other variants but he is separate to
delta delta doesn't have this uh this
dropout and so it's a real red flag that
they're looking for at the moment and
they say that in in the last week cases
of this uh s-gene drop out have risen by
141
so certainly that is what they call an
early signal uh of concern something
they're going to look at very very
closely